hey guys dr. Burke here in this video
we're gonna talk about diagnosing your
stool alright number one if the stool is
hard little round chunks like little
balls that are dry that means you're
doing too much protein I'll have people
do like protein shakes and that's all
they're consuming no vegetables and
that's what they get okay because if the
protein absorbs a lot of the water in
the fluid from your intestinal tract
number two unform flakes it's almost
like a borderline diarrhea and that
usually comes from eating certain people
eat salads or even the kale shake or
some leafy greens they haven't developed
the enzymes to actually digest that
material or maybe they ate too much and
the microbes that live off the fiber are
overwhelmed and so they just cause you
to dump it okay so that means you're
doing a little too much of the wrong
type of salad or green okay you have to
mix it up change the vegetable to
something else okay and the enzymes that
are supposed to digest that come from
microbes because microbes make enzymes
so it's really a lack of a certain
microbe number three floating stool that
means that you have too much fat in your
stool because you don't have enough bile
B I le from the gallbladder in which
case you need some gallbladder formula
to help some give you some bile to help
to break down that fat okay next one
skid marks on the toilet and inside the
toilet
that's a pancreas problem because you
don't have the enzyme called lipase and
the pancreas so the pancreas is not
releasing an enzyme to digest that and
you get this like black tarry stool type
thing okay so you need more pancreatic
enzymes alright and by the way
pancreatic enzymes are in the gall
bladder formula so I put that in there
called pancreatic
the digestive part of the pancreas okay
lastly dry stool that happens to be a
lack of just friendly flora friendly
bacteria it means you need more
probiotic that helps you lubricate that
and helps you digestion and creates kind
of a little
occasionally now one last thing is if
you have blood in the stool or it's red
you know rule out if it's a beat
situation if you just eight beats
because that could cause it or it could
be a hemorrhoid okay that's the usual
common cause okay and lastly I don't
know if you've ever saw a stool sample
I'm not sure if you have so I actually
brought one to show you what a stool
sample looks like okay so this is what
it looks like it's brown and it looks
like this okay so that's if you're
curious about what it looks like that's
what it looks like alright I'll see in
the next video have a good one let's go
show this to the patients come on hey
Joanne hi good to see you again
so this stool sample came through so I
just want to know we have the stool
sample that we tested so I just wanted
to make sure that you had that the
results of that
oh that's inside oh okay you want to see
it you want to but you see it's the
stool sample came out so I have your
stool sample all set that we had it
tested and the results are inside you
did one open now oh my gosh it's just
it's um it's the stool sample oh my god
you thought I meant the actual stool
sample yeah okay good so this wasn't
yours then yeah so Roxanna we have the
results of the stool sample and I just
wanted to give those to you inside that
you wanted to have done but run you know
I had the lab do it so we have the
results what hey guys thank you so much
for watching your next step is to click
the share button below and let's spread
the word